I wonder
your thoughts if I may on the fact that
people are anxious about speaking out to
criticize the government because they
don't want to end up in jail
okay emotions are obviously very very
high people are in Desperate shock and
of course they're raising questions
about an area
that is in an earthquake zone that's
been known for many many years but
clearly when you look at the scale of
what has happened the biblical
proportions of the amount of people
involved and also that the
infrastructure has been so damaged that
the ability to get to people has been
hampered what we're seeing I think on
our TV screens is absolutely
heart-rending and heartbreaking and the
International Community has got to do
all that it can now to gather around
turkey and make sure that we are with
the country not just in these next few
days but for weeks and months ahead
the moment if you were foreign secretary
potentially when you're foreign
secretary what would you be saying to a
government that has made its people so
terrified of being locked up that they
won't speak out even though no equipment
is coming to get their loved ones from
under this Rubble many people have been
arrested and are now being put on trial
for they say trying to get Aid to areas
of the country that is not being helped
by the military
well look I'm hearing the reports that
are coming through and I recognize that
there have been issues raised about the
nature of democracy in Turkey over many
many years and indeed I've raised these
issues in Parliament in the past
today the issue is still about saving
the lives that remain tomorrow and next
week it's about the bitter temperatures
and how you House close and feed people
going ahead and then it's about the
Reconstruction efforts so yes there are
questions about the nature of how
democracy Works in Turkey those are
questions that will come up this year
because it's an election year in that
country but my principal concern must be
the humanitarian effort that must take
place and I say that because I represent
in my own constituency one of the
largest turkish-speaking populations in
the United Kingdom where people are
still traumatized and worried about the
scale of damage and still are waiting
for news of their loved ones
what more can we do to help those in
Syria
the debt campaign today it's open you
can give funds and our government will
match those funds and that's the right
thing to do and there will be more
coming as the UN and the whole arsenal
of support across the global Community
come together it's very likely that we
will see the numbers of those dying rise
and of course next door in Syria it's
much harder to get the news and very
very sadly the infrastructure there
because of the conflict that's gone on
for so many many years will have been
even worse so this is a major biblical
catastrophe and the global Community has
to stand with the people of turkey and
Syria notwithstanding some of the
challenging politics of the region
looking at these images and the
desperate scenes of those that have lost
loved ones here many many people still
trapped beneath this wreckage a
situation that I have witnessed in
uh Ukraine recently as well as missiles
continue to rain down at apartment
blocks there as a result of the war with
Russia we saw president zielinski
yesterday's addressing parliament in
Westminster hall both houses of course
he wants Jets should we give them to him
well look
um I think that we must be serious when
we say that
Ukraine must Prevail uh so the call for
jets is not a new call it's an old call
the question for the International
Community at this point is not to do
anything that is offensive rather than
defensive and would see jets used in
Russian airspace itself and those
guarantees will have to be assured this
has got to be an Allied response across
the NATO family the request at the
moment is for s-16s we here in the UK
predominantly have typhoons and f-35s
and of course there's the issue of
training we're already training Pilots
that must be right I think Rishi sunak
is correct to say that nothing is off
the table and what will take place over
the coming days I suspect and weeks is
very coordinated action across the NATO
community
I think it was a yes or no answer
actually Mr Lammy do you does labor
think that president zelenski
should he be should he be getting the
Jets that he's asking for
look I think that I want to see Ukraine
Prevail but let me be clear as the
official opposition this is not a moment
for a lack of consensus in Parliament
what we saw in yesterday was the shared
consensus that labor has forged with the
government and across actually all
opposition parties uh I haven't got
access to the information that the Prime
Minister and the defense secretary will
have I'm not privy to the conversations
that they'll be having with other NATO
allies and so this must rightly be a
judgment for them to make but I support
them in that difficult balance between
ensuring that we have the best defensive
posture but that we are not using
weapons offensively and seeing an
escalation in this war and in this
conflict
thank you